se mueve Estados Unidos hacia una
despenalización de la marihuana a nivel
Federal
bien creo que más allá de la
despenalización lo que hay es una movida
de corte electoral que es obviamente
comprensible tampoco tiempo de las
elecciones de medio término pero que sin
embargo responde a una demanda social
muy grande y a lo que yo llamo Un
quander y un conflicto cultural muy
importante en los Estados Unidos un país
donde en un frágil equilibrio o sea
siempre sincretizado lo que Max debe
haber llamaba la ética protestante y por
el otro lado el espíritu del capitalismo
no entonces hay un cuádricultural pero
también hay un problema legal enorme
Porque mientras la marihuana está
reconocida para el consumo recreativo
por 17 estados y su consumo bajo
prescripción médica Es legal en 37
estados y tres territorios la paradoja
Es que la ley federal la proscribe lo
cual va a crear un conflicto serio
seguramente ya no solamente a nivel
cultural sino también a nivel jurídico
usted lo mencionabas acerca de unas
elecciones de medio término como analiza
esta decisión de bailen de Cara a estos
comicios
bien es parte de una batería de medidas
y además de legislaciones que el
presidente ha ido tomando enfocándose en
grupos que yo pienso que a los
demócratas consideran que son todavía
gananciables en el marco de la
acumulación de apoyo electoral esta ha
sido una elección muy complicada para el
partido demócrata ha empezado con una
fuerte factura de apoyo que han perdido
debido a la guerra y a las consecuencias
económicas sobre el precio de los
commodities la subida del alza los
carburantes les pasó en marzo a mayo una
fuerte factura Y hoy día después de una
recuperación paulatina creo que se ve
forzados ante la nueva crecida del costo
de los combustibles ante los nuevos
efectos de las medidas fijadas por la
OPEP a improvisar algunas medidas que
tienden yo creo que a tocar sectores
electorales que los cuales el voto
demócrata se concentra en este caso la
población afroamericana el mismo
presidente va a Irene ha declarado que
esta medida es sin duda una medida para
beneficiar a gente Blanca lo ha dicho
hoy día y creo que ese es el enfoque
electoral que le están dando a esta
aprobación señor Fajardo quienes
rechazan la despenalización dicen que el
consumo de la marihuana conduce a otros
delitos más graves que cree usted
Yo pienso que los estados unidos no ha
terminado de ponerse de acuerdo en la
mirada del Estado sobre el tema de la
marihuana y la mirada de la sociedad
americana hay sin duda una criminalidad
incipiente en los Estados Unidos hoy
pero no veo una relación directa con el
consumo de la marihuana por el otro lado
hay un estado carcelario que es sobre la
base de la penalización de la marihuana
se ha constituido en uno de los focos de
inequidad de social sobre todo en
Estados como California una profesora
mía la profesora Ruth gilmore Wilson
tiene un libro que yo lo invito a
revisar se llama el gulag de oro en
California la ley de los tres strikes
que permite que se encierre con mucha
facilidad a quien Porta marihuana se ha
convertido en la base de la industria de
las prisiones que concentra un gran
capital humano es decir es un conflicto
político social cultural y ahora también
legal que yo pienso que hay que ver en
los siguientes días podría terminar en
la suprema corte dado que hay un
conflicto entre las leyes federales y
locales y sobre todo en la concepción
sobre Si es o no Es legal la marihuana